[Applause]
Euphoria in the dressing room early this
morning Manchester City finally with
their Champions League trophy
brought back to their party in Istanbul
well the squad celebrated until dawn
the European Cup welcomed extra baggage
to take home winning it to be weighing
heavily on them and the morning after
securing it the winners medals also
still hung around the necks of City's
Heroes ilkaigondo and emerging from the
team Hotel another for the collection
for the captain who's picked up three
trophies in a month
with Turkish Heritage locals tried to
catch his attention
Edison was one of the few players they
could also see but the goalkeeper wasn't
in the mood for selfies either
perhaps it's understandable the city
players want to keep their distance so
reluctant to show their faces after a
grueling final and late night partying
they've won so much but they haven't
exactly won over locals desperate for a
glimpse of the treble winners
but Jack grealish is proud dad did stop
to speak to Sky News how does it feel
amazing what did Jack tell you amazing
amazing
less memorable was the experience
leaving the attituck stadium
lengthy delays after the victory over
into Milan and a search for taxes on
Gridlock roads back into the center
inside the stadium players were
reflecting on City's greatest ever
season I'm still trying to realize it
um it's it's unbelievable and I think
day by day will get better and better
yeah
Guardiola will be thinking about the
next Target a quadruple perhaps but
never far away is the club's Fate on
charge the financial wrongdoing by the
Premier League charges they deny
but for now partying is the priority
back home for a parade the Premier
League trophy the FA Cup and at last the
European Cup to raise on the open top
bus through the streets of Manchester on
Monday night Rob Harris Sky News
Istanbul